wir sprechen jetzt live mit marcel remus
er es bekannter immobilienmakler auf
mallorca schönen guten abend schön dass
sie sich zeit für uns nehmen heute harry
muss wie erleben sie denn die stimmung
gerade nach der ausgesprochenen
reisewarnung
ja es ist genau so wie es ja schon
gezeigt haben beitrag ist es eine
komplette katastrophe für mallorca man
muss sich vorstellen
wir hatten ja auch der ist eine
wahnsinnig hatte der ausgangssperren
zeit dh die in großen die ganzen
gastronomen die ganzen werte die
restaurants die theorie keiner wusste
wie es weitergehen sollte jetzt hatten
die paar wochen noch die paar monate bis
oktober bis november und jeder taten
kämpft ums überleben und ist schon in
weißer gesehen haben meines onkels einem
dies ende oktober vorbei und jetzt also
am freitag angehört haben und das
sozusagen wieder eine reisewarnung gilt
dass das auswärtige amt mallorca als
risikogebiet eingestuft hat es ist das
größte desaster dass wir alle wir sind
am boden zerstört keiner weiß wie es
weitergeht
man muss sich auch vorstellen man hat ja
grundsätzlich hier auf mallorca als
unternehmensvision und ist sehr kurze
zeitpunkt braucht geld zu verdienen
das heißt wenn jetzt die saison die
gesamte der tourismus eine stelle und
man liest ja auch dass die
fluggesellschaften schon direkt zurück
nach deutschland fliegen
es ist ein desaster und ich glaube ganz
ganz ganz viele wissen gar nicht wie es
weitergehen sollte und sie handeln ja
mit immobilien
sie sagen ist es ein desaster ist es für
sie auch ein desaster oder sind sie
nicht so betroffen
ja ich will mich da ist gar nicht nur in
dem bereich beschweren weil ich muss
ganz er ist ein großer teil der toy
konnte man auf die war schon sehr gut
verkaufen und ich muss auch sagen meine
gründe in diesem segment handling oder
ist man das klientel ab 150 euro aus das
sind investoren die nach dem franken wie
sie ihr geld investieren können bis
mallorca trotzdem destination nummer
eins ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen auch
nach der ausgangssperre die ersten
kunden wieder wurst mallorca haben gute
gründe auf der insel hat aber es geht
natürlich auch gar nicht in der form um
nicht sondern es wird bin ich um die
massen hier auf der insel die kleinen
cafés bars die kleinen café ist die
zahlen restaurants die überhaupt nicht
wissen wohin der kauf steht die
überhaupt nicht wissen wie es
weitergehen sollte kosten gehen weiter
das ganze programm und diese finanzielle
unterstützung hier in spanien gesetzt
ist ja auch nicht nur einfach in
deutschland das ist dann wirklich mal
die gelder ist endlich förderung
angekommen also ich sehe wie schwarz und
ich glaube wir wissen noch gar nicht was
für die katastrophe dagegen auf uns
zukommt ja das wird meine nächste frage
vielleicht so gefühlige frage versetzen
wir uns in ein ca 20 21 wie sieht da
unsere lieblingsinsel aus was denken sie
ich hoffe dass trotzdem ganz ganz viele
bundesbürger nach new york reisen um
einfach mal york und solisten zu stärken
und zu unterstützen ich glaube das ist
das was sie jetzt brauchen dass wir
zusammenrücken dass wir uns gegenseitig
unterstützen dass wir mal york
unterstützen dass wir irgendwie in
dieser krise ja durch die krise kommen
dass alle gesund bleiben
ich hoffe dass mallorca kann dieses
jahren ab und vor beliebt ist es wird
ganz anders sein also mit sicherheit
dann auch diese ganzen regionen
kleiderkammer ball haben wird sich
komplett verändern wenn es denn
überhaupt noch mal der form zu geben
wird das ist wieso die große frage aber
ich hoffe einfach dass nach wie vor die
menschen am new yorker glauben dass ihr
das alle hier durch die krise kommen
verlieren muss danke an sie für den
moment und wir wünschen ihnen natürlich
trotzdem dass sie auch den nächsten tage
die sonne genießen auf mallorca sie auch
schön abend tschüss